I would say I knew about it Denis had
mentioned it to me a couple of I'd say a
year earlier but we really only come on
two months before and it's never enough
time smaller films makeup and hair we're
often only brought on to two to three
weeks before and I think on this one it
was maybe four I want to say four weeks
June maybe four or five weeks with a
little early prep that I started doing
from the US a couple of months earlier
it's really never enough we're pretty
much the last ones in and that's my only
gripe about the world of what we do in
terms of prep on on a films like this I
think you know every project is
different every director is different
the way the costume designer or the
production itself are working and where
you're shooting so if you happen to be
on a you know a production say shooting
in London or shooting in Los Angeles and
the office is there and all the actors
are there it's it's much much easier for
us this was a little bit harder because
we were filming in Budapest a lot of
pre-production was done in Los Angeles I
was in Boston working on a film Carrie
was in London costume was in Canada so
it was a bit more difficult but I'd say
we all start you know I came on board
quite early and met with Denis and we
started exchanging some photographs of
what he thought this may be Roger
Deakins and I met a few times for dinner
in Los Angeles so we'd have a sense of
what they because they really story
aboard the two of them storyboard six
I'd say it was six months to a year
prior to my coming on board that there
had been enough discussions of what what
this world may or may not be and then we
kind of fine-tune everything you know
because it's one of my favorite films
and it's so iconic when I started in the
80s of my first design job or department
heading job on was a sci-fi television
series in the 80s
I remember referencing Blade Runner
quite a lot and of course Marvin
Westmore
the makeup design of the film was its
iconic to this day
but I didn't really I knew that Denis
and Roger wanted to make a different
film this wasn't really necessarily
Blade Runner 30 years later this was a
film n't unto itself so there were
elements we borrowed but I'd say
elements is the key word
certainly for Denis because we were not
remaking Blade Runner we had our own
film to make and there were little
elements I went back and saw the film
funnily enough when we wrapped and I
went back to Los Angeles I saw the the
original film was on television I was
really glad I waited in pre-production I
watched a blu-ray version maybe halfway
through when I stopped because it was
starting to interfere with ideas I was
trying to come up with you know with a
costume designer and with Carrie a hair
designer that we had to just maybe step
back from that a little bit so it
started on with that group Renee and
Dennis Gassner production designer so
they sort of come onboard first and then
live was brought on board and then I you
know suggested Carrie Warren I really
admired his hair work from Gatsby and
you know all those films I think all
kidman so I thought it was a very good
idea and when Denis and the studio came
to me
you know how should we approach this
because it was very much the kind of
film where I think on paper certainly
for me and almost and I'm sure Carrie
will agree you kind of read it and think
Blade Runner what that you know it's a
bit overwhelming and as it came back
into reality of being based in reality I
thought it was a great choice so Carrie
who I've known for many years came on
board and then we subsequently put our
teen our respective teams together
I had a great group of people who I've
worked with two of them before so that
was very helpful for me on the scope of
a film like that and we know we worked a
lot with visual effects I would say more
on the makeup side I mean hair and
makeup sort of are so harmonious and it
goes hand-in-hand
I think visual effects has become much
more part of the world of makeup and
visual effects as well because they know
scanned everything you know CG indicator
markers that we draw on it sort of
become very collaborative as well I know
that Denis likes me to be on set all the
time so what will happen is I'll
generally choose a few actors that I can
work with directly overseeing their look
or doing their makeup day to day so for
instance you know Ryan Jared Leto Robin
Wright but I do find that there are
other directors and certainly other hair
and makeup designers who work very
differently who don't do the set as
often because there's so much prep
involved I find that for Danny that's
not really my style I need to be on set
I need to be where the camera is it was
you know quite involved with Ryan a lot
of out of kit makeup effects and blood
and sweat and and things that I really
needed to be there for their other films
each departments different you might be
having to prep wigs or or you know
makeup we're doing fittings that kind of
thing it just depends on the film but
that one certainly was very hands-on
because Ryan is in every scene of this
film and and I'd be prepping by phone or
at night or on the weekends makeup and
visual effects you know it's always been
I've always worked really traditionally
it's costume hair and makeup I mean the
way Carrie and I work and what do you
think of this we're doing that with
Robin what do you think if we do you
know but with V effects what's
interesting is sometimes were in we're
sort of helping them create a character
so I obviously can't take any credit for
the she's um in the film with Mariette
played by McKenzie and Anna de Armas
that is nothing to do with hair makeup
that's a brilliant visual effect with
some CG indicators on say what we called
new Rita and old Rita or Rachel that was
CG indicators as a character creation
that's purely in the visual effects
world that took 150 people and and John
Nelson and Paul it's it's absolute sheer
brilliance that we just enable a little
bit but other times I think what's
happening
say the pink joy when she's larger than
life's of course they've you know
augmented her size but that's still
fundamentally in camera is a makeup job
the contact lenses are practical
they are sclera lenses the audiences are
very knowledgeable some people still
think that that's all visual effects and
we laugh about it because I think it's a
job the jobs properly done but sometimes
we always have to say well actually that
was in camera and that's very much a
denis villeneuve and Roger Deakins way
of working everything is in camera but
there are other films where they may
actually create the pink character and
I'm you know very quick to say sometimes
the very old techniques I think that we
used were very much part of the film and
and the reflection with Ryan Gosling is
Kay and you know the pink joy was always
in camera it's usually a question of
time there's never enough of it it feels
for me in recent years because we come
on quite late I know they rushed me to
Budapest a few weeks early suddenly we
weren't you know we weren't meant to be
there till the end of June which I think
was an oversight on their part too you
know Denise saying I need you to be here
and you know I'm on another film and
we're all over the place I would say the
challenge to be honest the challenge
really was a lot of the actors were
committed to other projects and I know
Kari couldn't attest to this it would
make me it was frustrating because I
would have would have Robin Wright for
instance who's committed to a television
series in America hugely successful one
and we have her for eight days or 10
days so we know costume makeup hair we
know we have her flying in for 12 hours
one day maybe we get her she leaves
she's coming back to film Jared Leto may
or may not be in the film so I would say
that everyone tried very hard to keep it
as
concise and organized as possible but
for me was quite difficult because I
would have jared leto
confirming he's in the film Alcon saying
yes we've got him we're delighted
everyone's happy it's Jared Leto - next
thing a 15-hour day on the set in
Budapest I get back to the hotel and I'm
having to wait to phone Los Angeles to
speak with Jared and about his contact
lenses and that's another hour - and
then all the semantics all the
organisation that goes into that while
I'm on set 15 hours a day we can't cut
his hair we can't do this you know
there's a lot of restrictions placed on
on us and we have to come up with things
that will work within the realm of kind
of possibility and we came up with two
possible looks for him I would say it
was a huge source of anxiety for me I
don't mind telling people that and the
contact lenses were a challenge
absolutely hand-painted based on a
friend of his who had lost his sight and
and you know they're hand-painted and
there are two people literally in the
world I mean what a job I hand paint
contact lenses it's not something you
just look up in the yellow pages so
there's one person available and we had
ten days so it was a lot of favours
involved to get these what other
challenges I would say coming up with
things pretty quickly or not having the
opportunity to meet someone Dave
Bautista actually was a huge challenge
because it was contingent maybe six
months before Denis rang me up and he
said do you think you can make this guy
look older now I'd worked with Dave
Bautista briefly on a Bond film and he's
one of the greatest nicest people ever
and I knew Dave really wanted the film
and I wanted to help him as well but
they were concerned that he they'd only
seen him in guardians of the galaxy and
inspector and could he look older which
I knew he could so I I called colleagues
of mine in Atlanta where they were
filming guardians of the galaxy
maybe six months before filming and they
did a makeup test - my specification and
it worked and we put photos side-by-side
Alcon signed off on it
Dave subsequently was hired and I'm very
happy about that because it could have
gone another route and he's terrific in
the film and it's a very traditional
aging with latex and it was a you know
not a simple makeup but it was really an
old-school technique that I knew would
work in Denis was very happy with it and
to have Dave on the film was such a
bonus for everybody
[Music]
[Music]